what are you looking forward to as you
move into a new chapter of your life i'm
just excited for what i don't know yet
you know everything is new to me so
you know i'm excited well seems safe to
say asap rocky and rihanna are soaking
up that excitement now that baby boy is
here and et has new details about life
with their bundle of joy i'm trying to
enjoy it as much as i could the power
couple welcomed a baby boy back in may
and now a source tells e.t why the
couple's been maintaining a low profile
since his arrival it's simple quote
privacy has become increasingly
important to them when it was just the
two of them they go out at all hours of
the day and night and interact with fans
now with the baby they're a little more
protective i'm very realistic it's true
since becoming parents ree and rocky
have only been spotted out a handful of
times first at a barber shop in london
in early july
at barbara
how is this happening right now
yeah fans were in total disbelief seeing
the rapper getting a haircut while his
girl snapped pics with some locals later
that month the beauty mogul supported
her beau during his lollapalooza set in
paris and back in the big apple the two
enjoyed a chic parents night out at hot
spot carbone i know i had to make it
work but don't worry as much as
rihanna's enjoying this family time our
source promises the navy she'll be back
to work soon enough work work work work
work work
work work work work the source adds
she's one of the hardest working people
out there and she can definitely have it
all be a hands-on mom and have an
impressive career i can do whatever i
want that's right reed becoming a mama
doesn't mean music is taking a back seat
yes you're still going to get music from
me maybe a lullaby i could see you and
asap dropping demos in the studio
oh my goodness not a lullaby my fans
would kill me they waited this long for
a lullaby letting us sleep with this
music they're like we are grown one more
thing that might be on fans minds since
regate birth
[Music]
what's rihanna and asap's son's name
well our source explains that she will
announce it in her own way when she's
ready
[Music]